-♪ Best Friends Challenge ♪
♪ Oh, yeah ♪
-Now, this game works
like "The Newlywed Game,"
but for friends.
We're gonna take turns reading
questions about each other
from the Best Friends Box,
and then we're gonna try
to write down the same answer.
We didn't plan any of this out.
In fact, I've played this
with Tina Fey,
Justin Timberlake, Viola Davis,
and I've never gotten one
question right with any of them.
But anyways -- But let's
change that all tonight.
So, here we go.
This is your marker
and your pad here.
I'll read
the first question here.
All right.
Okay.
Demi,
if I were a Disney Princess,
which one would I be?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Clock ticking ]
All right. Time's up.
-[ Laughing ] Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-There's no time. All right.
Demi, you can show it
to that camera.
What did you write?
What Princess would I be?
[ Drumroll ]
Oh, I didn't know that.
Cinderella is your --
-Yeah.
-Yes.
-I said Belle from
"Beauty & the Beast."
[ Laughter ]
[ Sad trombone notes ]
But I put --
-"Mama"?
-I put "Maybe Moana"
just in case.
I didn't know.
I was just hedging my bets.
My girls love Moana now,
so I didn't want to take
their princess.
-Oh, got it.
-But I would be Belle,
'cause that's more my --
-Cute.
-Remember, I'm 43 years old.
All right.
Good.
Here we go.
So, yeah.
-Okay.
-All right. Here we go.
-Ready?
-Yes.
Is that question one?
-Yeah, perfect.
All right. Here we go.
-If Demi was stranded
on a deserted island...
-Oh, no.
-...what one thing
would she bring with her?
♪♪
-Definitely not spicy pickles.
[ Laughter ]
Oh.
What would she bring?
Oh!
[ Clock ticking ]
♪♪
[ Marker scribbling ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Marker clacks ]
Okay.
Ready?
-Okay.
-Here's my answer.
Your two dogs --
Batman and the other one.
-[ Laughing ]
"The other one."
[ Laughter ]
And Cinderella.
-Oh, that's right.
Cinderella and Batman!
What did you say?
-I said my iPhone.
-Oh, my gosh!
Come on!
[ Sad trombone notes ]
-I'm a terrible owner.
I'm a terrible --
-You were talking
about your dogs.
You love your dogs.
-I know,
but if you had your iPhone,
you might get service,
and you might could call
your way off the island.
-I don't even get service
in New York City.
I mean, come on.
Deserted island.
All right,
I will read the next question.
Here we go.
Ready?
-I should have said my dogs.
-If we were going to binge-watch
a TV show together,
what show would we pick?
I know.
Here we go.
[ Clock ticking ]
♪♪
[ Marker clacks ]
-This is not gonna be right.
-This is going to be right.
My BFF, what did you say?
It's like --
-[ Laughs ]
What did I say?
"Walking Dead."
-I know.
-That's similar.
-It's my favorite show.
-I said "Riverdale," which is --
[ Laughter ]
[ Sad trombone notes ]
That's too scary for me.
-Really?
-I can't do that.
"Riverdale", Archie --
this is scary enough for me.
There's a murder.
Jughead's involved.
It's a great show, "Riverdale,"
on The CW.
All right.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, ready?
-Yeah.
-If we became one person
and had to combine our names,
what would our new name be?
[ Clock ticking ]
♪♪
[ Marker clacks ]
[ Laughs ]
-Do we do it at similar times?
We got to get this one, BFF.
[ Drumroll ]
All right.
We have to combine our names.
What is your answer?
-Jemetria.
[ Laughter ]
-Similar.
Jemmi!
There you go.
Demi Lovato, everybody!
Demi's performing for us
later in the show!
Check out her new album,
"Tell Me You Love Me,"
on September 29th.
And her Fabletics workout gear
is available now.